hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to DPO now admittedly
the last episode that I played to this I
wasn't a hundred percent very good at
the game it was like my second time
playing ever but I've gotten a lot more
practice lately and I'm gonna show you
my fairly foolproof plan of epicness and
awesomeness that's gonna get you to the
number-one on the leaderboard guaranteed
or your money back
only $29.99 payments of $299 alright so
basically when you're starting out the
game it goes pretty simply and you guys
actually told me that I was incredibly
stupid which admittedly isn't much
different than what you guys normally
tell me what you guys nicely told me was
that bullet penetration actually is
incredibly useful because it's kind of a
damage booster as well as the ability to
fight through multiple objects and
multiple bullets and be able to beat
other players because you can actually
get your bullets through their bullets
which is very important because if
you're getting into the endgame and you
actually are trying to beat someone you
need to be able to pass through their
wall of bullets before you can get
anywhere or else you will have no
progress being done so when you're
starting out same thing when you're
starting out is pretty generic it's
pretty much simplistic in what you're
doing you do the basic stuff you do this
you void that you try not to get killed
by that guy and what I found is to be
the easiest not always the most exciting
but the easiest is just to go the
machine-gun route and then go for gun or
afterwards because the spray of bullets
combined with a lot of bullet speed can
definitely get you going like it can
surprise people it is so long as you can
ambush people because most of the big
people that you see on leaderboards will
usually be one of the triangle ones and
that's great for covering a lot of
options and getting a lot of getting a
lot of object kills which is good
because that does get points eventually
but what you're gonna want down the road
is the ability to one shoot while
running oh man there's some lag on the
server but you want to be able to shoot
while running and then you want to be
able to quickly hit and run people
without giving them too much of your
time be careful out there looking for
mods right now because I don't think
there's any official mod place so
anything that you might find that may
give
seemingly unfair advantage might
actually just be viruses so watch out
for that definitely watch out for kick
oh I love [ __ ] fool [ __ ] me
competition seems to be kind of fierce
on this map I'm not gonna lie I can't
seem to get an escape I imagine over on
the right side I might get a little more
solace but I gotta get over there oh
that guy's going nuts
Alexis calm down it's not that important
it's just a video game okay so I'm on
the other side of the map but I have a
funny feeling that's not gonna be any
better than where I was before I'm gonna
be in a similar situation
whoa Hays a swarm no don't do it no no
no no no no no no no no no no don't
don't I don't want to mess with you you
don't want to mess with me I will kill
eachother it won't be good for anybody
as long as I can get out of the way of
your bullets come on come on fight yes
got him okay so gunner is the next
upgrade that I generally do okay because
it just allows you to absolutely bombard
people just like that and then destroy
them and I'm kind of in a corner here
the thing is you will recuperate health
if you wait long enough but you just
need to be able to wait long enough so
that your health goes all the way back
up to 100% because after a while I mean
health regen is one thing but that's
like for in combat health regen what you
want is you want to be able to just
smash and move as fast as you can't see
like that it just regenerates all the
way up to full after a while no way bro
ah too late bro sorry couldn't do
anything for you bro it's just the way
it is bruh there's a lot of battle
through supremacy going on here whoa got
him oh why didn't I get points for that
[ __ ] okay so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try to move
towards the center of the map even
though I'm not in the center at the
moment we're almost maxed level so the
most important thing now is just to stay
alive I am on the leaderboard but I'm
only a lowly number 6 compared to number
one who has 150,000 points that's just
because if you get number one after a
while you can just kind of sit in the
middle and then enjoy the
the fruits of your labor which is just
all of the Octagon holes in the center
of the man pentagonal it's it's gonna
run counteraction who's gonna win I
think me
I think me oh [ __ ] maybe not me ha ha it
was me okay so I'm gonna get full-on
bullet speed because just to be able to
chase people down with my bullets is
super duper important how about I just
spray in this general area and you're
probably dead
that's what I imagine okay so I'm number
one number one I'm not number one I'm
number four but those are the giant ones
that I was telling you guys about
they're really hard to kill so it's hard
to get the last hit on it because only
the last hit gives you points no and
these little bastards will try to hunt
you down and then they got their big
momma bastards that are also a part of
it but nothing to worry about nothing to
worry about
because the other thing about a gunner
is that it's very easy to get last hit
on something like that because of how
many bullets you put out so long as you
can keep the pressure on then you should
be able to do something what you think
you're doing buddy yeah that guy that
guys probably can't win against me
because of the distribution of his
bullets besides compared to the focus of
mine and the distribution of his like
it's obviously which one of us win
that's why he's running away like a
little baby you should be wearing the
mark of heart a little easier though
just to go for all the pentagon's
because there's just and doodles of them
there's a new Dalls of them they there's
more fighters the more of these
Pentagon's come in I said Pentagon
Pentagon's yeah Pentagon's pentagonal
and pentagonal pen pen pen t-55 sided
geometric shapes is what I'm talking
about what I want number one how did I
get number one oh the number one guy
must have died but see it's just sound
easy to get number one when you just get
qoodles and oodles of all the points
that you could possibly want and then
you're able to kill people with reckless
abandon whenever you get confronted by
them just
lonely marca fart what do you want from
me oh yeah another we got another angler
the guys that are so scared they just
shoot out of every orifice on their body
and hope for the past I'm out rare you
wanna mess with the mark I used to be
triple dick Rick but then I I hung up
that lifestyle because it wasn't working
out for me and then I went to a more
reasonable aspect which was not that oh
it's good I'll let them Duke it out I'll
let them Duke it out even though alexis
is getting a lot of points and I'm not
too keen on that I should come in there
but with two of them they cover so much
of the area that it's very hard to make
sure that I actually kill their bullets
before they get to me which I can do I
can definitely do it's totally possible
yeah that's right Rob you know who the
best deals you know who the best oh [ __ ]
just getting a little dance little dance
ha ha ha and then Alexis you got a
runaway cuz you can't handle the market
fart no one can I'm still number one oh
god I gotta get out of here because
these fighters are just messing me up so
I'm gonna just go it's another Gunnar
whoa no you don't know you don't know
you don't know you don't the only thing
scary is just another Gunnar coming my
way came 2 the wrong neighberhood rod
las' rod Lee's Rita laws Oh Alexis is
gunning for me
alexis is getting close I don't like
that I kind of want to just take care of
Alexis but I don't have enough movement
speed it's hard to keep number one when
Alexis keeps coming for me and he won't
come fight me he's a big bubble blowing
baby who's too scared he's you and sting
oh it's a Gunnar battle so I got a lot
of points and I got a good lead over
Alexis but I I'm not it's not cutting
the mustard I need to go let go on the
outskirts and try to kill some
lower-level people to be able to get a
lot of points really quickly or else I'm
not gonna go anywhere Plus that is
Alexis is that Alexis where's the origin
point of your balls Alexis is that you
all access or is that Rob trying to come
up and steal glory so long as someone
else takes these fighters like I'm
perfectly okay whoo oh that is Rob hi
Rob how you doing Rob
well we're gonna have ourselves a good
old time when we're fighting together
together forever you can't run away from
your fate Robbie Rob did I kill him no
yes Robbie must have killed Alexis and
then I devastated everything yeah
there's some new sets of guns that I
haven't quite seen before like that one
holy [ __ ] that's actually really slow
bullets though so easy to avoid don't
even whoa hello I'm in a capable lead I
want to get to a hundred thousand if I
can get to a hundred thousand that'll
actually mean something to me I can
engage and I can beat people and then I
can trounce them and then I can make fun
of their parents in front of them that's
my only goal in life
oh really humiliate everybody that I've
ever beaten I do I call this one the
shimmy maneuver if I see someone over in
the distance that shooting bullets but I
can't quite see their body I just kind
of shimmy my bullets all over the place
until I get one eventually and that's my
key sticks yes shimmy shimmy flare me
flammie flim-flammery shimmy shimmy
shimmy flammie for him don't even try
you [ __ ] you wanna mess with me you're
gonna die real badly I'm not gonna lie
this guy who's taking over the center
with no name seems to have a good morph
or whatever the upgrade is I don't even
know what it is but it seems plenty
powerful oh hello Alexis welcome back
but unfortunately you're dead yep okay
got that one 196 hours and that's a lot
of points this one's mine you cannot
beat me on this one no no no did I get
that [ __ ] you dude you took all my work
I will kill you I will destroy you and
everything that you've ever built you
want to think that you're cool you the
opposite of that is true just imagine
that I said that correctly and you were
intimidated by it I thought I might have
had him and then lost him but them and
that I just didn't have them ultimate
deep yeah yep yeah
so now that I got a hundred thousand I'm
gonna play more aggressively and I'm
actually gonna chase after these sons of
[ __ ] just as soon as a gunner over
here who's a gunner who's a gun in
gunner come after you just as soon as I
get my health back but not a second
sooner all right here we go coming for
you killer of world is killer of now
dead you're welcome little guy who I
helped I did that intentionally because
I'm a hero damn it Carson open Gangnam
style who's up here huh huh I want to
give you all a fair shot at victory but
I don't think you're gonna get it good
spin equals team how about shoot equals
dead I like that option that's kind of
my favorite at the moment like please no
man he walked into death so quickly I
didn't even get a chance to read his
name triple dick Rick oh I used to be
you I used to want you to ban marca
farts oh yeah you want to play brah you
want to play brah you want to play
breath come on dammit I want more I need
more you thought you could run away and
escape the answer is probably because I
can't seem to finish you off cuz I'm so
slow I'm just gonna shimmy and Shammi
until something dies maybe I don't know
I don't see any more spray of bullets
who is that you is that you Damian oh
there you are oh sorry didn't you got
caught in the crossfire there I'm after
Damian I got two people coming in on
both sides they better not be
coordinating the sandwich me I don't
like being part of a man meat sandwich
exactly the opposite of what I enjoy how
about no if you're spinning it doesn't
make me want to join your team I hate to
break it to you but that's not how the
world works you is kill you want his
kill huh you want his kill
you want this kill match power oh [ __ ]
you Alexis don't don't try to
double-team me it won't work well he
probably will work but I'll blame lag or
something you'll never see victory ring
sporadically I got him I got him
no I didn't get him no that was
something else sorry I thought I got him
false alarm it's totally cool but where
did he go
Oh doctor donut I'm so sorry it has to
be like this I'm very sorry doctor donut
I apologize sincerely you just cannot
beat tomorrow [ __ ] even gunner you
gunner you got the wrong upgrades I need
to recover though I can't I can't
encounter anybody else where the hell
did max power go if he wasn't if he
wasn't if he didn't die then where the
hell did he go cuz that doesn't make any
sense that max power over there oh no
man I don't know what wha through wood
watts woo why do wasps whoa what wasps
whoa whoa what wasps whoo wad wasps whoa
wha gwaan whoa this must be terrifying
just for someone to start shouting
gibberish into your ear as you're trying
to murder them
watch watch whoa what was what oh hi
Alexis welcome back to the party I hate
to break it to you again but death is
upon you all right let's going let's not
play conservatively anymore let's be
aggressive oh there's one wise woo it's
what wise woo oh but did mine oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] that guy was coming for me oh [ __ ]
that guy's high damage well it might be
the end of my days but I'm gonna try my
best to get this and steal it from him
did I did I I don't know if I did it may
have been but I don't know alright this
is getting really dicey I think this is
gonna be it I think there's gonna be the
final battle I'm gonna go out
oh [ __ ] stole that kill well final
battle is exploitative as always I've
ever been just run in and steal other
people's work and then claim it as my
own
hi Alexis I sorry but your bullets cream
is not as strong hey your Schwartz she
did beat my oh I got you no yes I don't
know I can never tell when the bullets
do stop I assume that someone's dead but
that's not always the case that is
unfortunate for him grade I killed him
so good I almost got another upgrade
point did you see that and I crossed
200,000 yeah oh man I've never been this
high of a score before so I'm really
happy about this although I feel like I
feel like I'm almost too dominant to do
it now no one can stop the mark of art
the mark of art is reached critical mass
more points in any one tank should have
it is a presence in the world man I've
just been reigning supreme for way too
long
I feel bad at this point like I
legitimately kind of feel like maybe I
should hang up my crown and give other
people a chance like Squa over there or
no name McDouble gun hey squall you want
to fight squall
oh [ __ ] squaws might get me why am i
give me Juan got me okay well that is
all we will say about that I kind of let
him win but kind of I guess I don't have
no idea I was kind of playing around
that point but thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
want to see in the next video there's a
team mode and there's a new domination
game mode available on this one you can
find it through the link in the
description below play it's totally free
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video
what a bunch of bull ass